my city needs clarity nobody in my city
can compare to me every sunless I was
like a parody who see me before there's
no favoring me but the sharing me I'm
the last one you wanna go to war way you
better join and seem I'm the one you
smoking poet they labeled me a poem
because the topics they just rapping I'm
James Lipton I got a question for you
[ __ ] acting on whatever happened I'm
making music and B you drunk feels for
every trap crime scene so seen a few
replicas you leaving you charge it to
the game when I'm the [ __ ] [ __ ] I
gotta make this quick
[Music]
you know in the whole place I just I
just need to have a flow through I want
to two or three times a year I want to
do a real wine event that matters and
this is the place to do it
six weeks ago or so I uh I was in a
meeting here in LA and the gentleman I
was with I was with Lindsay and we were
David one of her mentors he said you
guys have a few minutes today and we
were like well we could make it happen
what's going on he's like you have to
come and see this amazing place so we
readjusted our schedules in the middle
of the kind of a weekday drove down here
and we're introduced to this amazing
gentleman that I'm excited to introduce
many of you to but others know we did a
little bit of a tour that I know many of
you have already done before I was
completely blown away even more exciting
to me as as we were going through the
incredible Wonderland that he's creating
here in the middle of LA I kind of
looked at the space were in and I said
you know for a long time I've been
wanting to put together a wine dinner in
LA and have a mix of my friends and
acquaintances get together and get to
know each other so something that's been
bouncing around in my mind for the last
18 months or so came together when I saw
this spot it's incredible energy that's
grittier so I'm having a lot of fun
watching you guys kind of mix and match
[Music]
cheers thank you get home safe love you
all
thank you cheers Cheers nice
[Music]
what's fun
[Music]
hey bruh sorry I'm late I think if you
love process and you're comfortable with
adversity if you have the stomach for it
and you love the journey over the over
the fruits and riches of that journey
you now have the two foundational pieces
to be a successful entrepreneur you know
a lot right now entrepreneurship is on
this interesting pedestal all of you
want to be one everybody wants to be one
but the truth is it sucks it's hard
almost everybody loses almost everybody
loses and and that is not something
we're having a conversation around you
genuinely have to like getting beat up
you generally have to like the conflict
you generally have to have an enormous
amount of patience to really actually
pull it off in a world where everybody
now gets to play in social media you
create a profile you're in the game in a
world where everybody gets in that back
we're about to realize that the far
majority people aren't good enough you
know we haven't had to quantify this
before because there were people in
place to filter people that America got
to see and most of them were qualified
to some level and so all we ever saw on
the news and in media was a curated
point zero zero zero one percent of us
and of that 90 percent weren't good
enough because the human that decided
that was flawed now what we have is an
ecosystem where everybody's getting out
there and saying they're great
the problem is the far majority aren't
going to be great at what they
pontificate at being great at and we're
gonna watch them fail in front of our
eyes
[Music]
[Music]